[Musique]
que se cache-t-il derrière les
expertises des économistes on entend
dire parfois que l'économie c'est cette
expert qui sera parfaitement vous
expliquer demain pourquoi ce qu'il avait
prévu hier ne s'est pas produit
aujourd'hui plus sérieusement les
économistes baptistes diverses
expertises à l'aide d'une démarche
scientifique mais pour qui des écoute ce
choix crée l'embarras difficile de
trancher et de trouver des réponses
définitives cette réforme des retraites
est-elle ou non opportune comment faire
pourquoi la faire la crédibilité de la
société savante des économistes vacille
des diagnostics dissonants conduisent à
des préconisations discordantes on a
pour habitude d'observer que chaque
courant de la pensée économique
s'efforce d'être politiquement
compatibles ainsi en général un discours
libéral qui met en avant les vertus du
marché sera appréciée par un courant de
droite alors que la gauche met sa
confiance dans les partisans de
l'intervention de l'État dans l'économie
le centre va aussi les entre ces deux
options quant à l'idéologie néo-marxiste
elle a pour habitude d'exiger de taxer
toujours plus le capital revenons au
retraites l'opportunité de la réforme
est largement établie elle n'est rejetée
qu'au nom d'une trop grande injustice
dénoncée par les économistes qui
s'affichent gauche compatibles pour la
plupart il y a aussi une quasi unanimité
médiatique sur la défense du système par
répartition une dose de capitalisation
est une option évoquée par certains
libéraux mais c'est inconcevable de la
part de ceux qui dénoncent la tyrannie
des marchés financiers enfin la nature
de la réforme a un temps fait débat le
rapport Tyrol Blanchard était pour une
réforme systémique universalité et
justice d'un système par points le
politique s'est résigné et à trancher en
faveur d'une réforme paramétrique les
économistes de la direction du Trésor
approuve cette réforme dans une vision
macro comptable ou finalement le recul
de l'âge vaut pour la diminution des
déficits ainsi forcer de constater que
la querelle vient de ce que les experts
bien qu'ils donnent l'impression
d'utiliser tous le même thermomètre ici
l'analyse économique n'indique pas les
mêmes mesures de la température ambiante
parce que ces experts appartiennent à
différents courants de la pensée
économique même s'il s'accorde sur le
chiffre a annoncé la température disant
il fait 30 degrés alors constat et leur
conclusion vont diverger c'est un peu
comme si certains mesurait en Celsius et
d'autres en Fahrenheit ainsi il ne faut
pas s'étonner que certains nous disent
il fait chaud il fait 30 degrés Celsius
et conseil d'ouvrir le parasol quand
d'autres nous disent il fait froid 30
degrés Fahrenheit parce que c'est -1
degré Celsius et conseil de faire un feu
il ne me reste qu'à souhaiter que les
économistes entretiennent cette
diversité des expertises car si le choix
e l'embarras avoir l'embarras du choix
et préférable le pluralisme des idées
commande que les théories continuent de
débattre entre elles et finalement
l'économiste pourra se borner à produire
et proposer des expertises variées et
plausibles car en démocratie ce sont les
électeurs qui choisissent les décideurs
politiques qui décident pour eux
disaient en substance un Nobel
d'économie chance Buchanan
[Musique]